Let's see if we can
write 59.2%, if we
can write this as a decimal.
Well, 59.2%, this
literally means
59.2 per cent, which
59.2 per 100, which literally
means 59.2 per 100, which
is the same thing as
59.2 divided by 100.
And If we were to divide 59.2
by 100, what would we get?
So this is the same thing
is 59.2 divided by 100.
So if we were to take 59.2, if
we wanted to divide it by 10,
we would move the decimal
over to the left once.
We would get 5.92.
But we want to divide it by
100, so we move the decimal
over to the left again.
We're dividing by 10
once, and then we're
dividing by 10 again.
Divide by 10 twice, you're
essentially dividing by 100.
So you move the decimal to
the left twice, you get 0.592.
And we'll just put a 0 out
here just to clarify things.
And we're done.
We've written
59.2% as a decimal.
We essentially just
divided this by 100,
which is dividing by 10
twice, moving the decimal once
to the left, and
then another time.
Or since we're dividing by
100, moving the decimal twice
to the left.
And we get 0.592.